the choice of Hanoi for Kim Jong Un's
second summit with US president Donald
Trump holds particular significance for
the North Korean leader Vietnam in the
u.s. once military enemies are now
partners in trade that history could
offer Kim a roadmap for making peace
with the world's mightiest superpower
and Kim is reported to have already
discussed vietnam style reforms to
transform his country's dilapidated
economy this is your bloomberg quick
take on why North Korea is looking for
lessons from Vietnam Vietnam has much in
common with North Korea both fought Wars
with the US and both are among the few
nations that retain communist elements
in the 80s both had poor performing
state-led economies and experienced the
shock of aid and trade loss when the
Soviet Union fell but how they responded
set them on different paths the
Vietnamese government introduced
market-led economic reforms downsized
its military improved relations with the
US and opened itself to the world for
aid investment and trade since then
Vietnam has completed more than a dozen
free trade agreements as it embraced a
socialist oriented market economy and
welcomed international companies like
South Korean tech giant Samsung which
has brought more than 100,000 jobs to
Vietnam and it's paying off average
annual incomes in Vietnam rose to almost
$2,600 in 2018 from about $400 in 2000
Vietnam now has one of the highest GDP
growth rates in the world North Korea on
the other hand has one of the lowest
that's because the North Korean
government headed in a much different
direction it adopted isolationist
self-reliant economic policies increased
military tensions by pursuing a nuclear
weapons program and took a
confrontational approach toward the u.s.
although its economy was stronger than
South Korea's in many areas through the
70s north Korea has fallen rapidly
behind and suffered devastating famines
since then
now the average annual North Korean
income is estimated to be just under
thirteen hundred dollars less than a
twentieth of South Korea's but there's a
glimmer of hope for the crumbling North
Korean economy
Kim has declared a new strategic line
which prioritizes economic development
this includes improving relations with
the international community and opening
special economic zones since Kim took
power in 2011 the number of these zones
designated to promote manufacturing and
trade has increased fivefold to 27 in
2018 he started visiting country leaders
starting with Xi Jinping in China
followed by many other diplomatic trips
Kim's regime seems intent on an economic
turnaround and Vietnam offers a route to
follow the country even sent its foreign
minister to North Korea with the message
that it stands ready to share its
experience
you
you